do you think Jesus and Muhammad are
worshiping the same God yes do you think
the Bible is the word of God partly what
about the Quran do you think the Quran
is the word of God
yes let's talk about life let's talk
about love if we talk about love then we
should talk about us and if we're
talking about us we need to talk about
growth they talk about you what they
should talk about both it's easier to
hate now and harder to care we used to
offer help now we gossip and stare
comment like swipe share hate used to be
now you see it everywhere beam Alum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
you might you guys may have noticed on
Instagram a sister called Lily she's a
non-muslim I don't know where she's from
her accent is I can't make it up to be
honest it sounds Australian but any
besides the point I think she's in
Turkey as well she's been doing some
videos which is actually very
interesting because she's actually act
asking chat gbt which is a artificial
intelligence and isn't it profound that
artificial intelligence that's been made
by human beings and it can never be like
us when it's asked simple rational
logical questions about God purpose of
life God being a man you know when it
comes to Christianity Jus being God it
says some profound things here is a
video clip just a couple of video clips
of her asking some simple basic life
questions that any human beings at one
point point of their life ask theirself
here let's react to insh and send a
message to Lily and invite her to Islam
cuz it seems like she's very very close
and maybe we can help her and send it
one of our guided prayer mats inallah
for absolutely free hey CH gbt do you
think God is real yes do you think Jesus
is a God or a prophet Prophet do you
think Jesus died for our sins or do you
think we to be held accountable for our
actions accountable do you think Jesus
and Muhammad are worshiping the same God
yes do you think the Bible is the word
of God partly what about the Quran do
you think the Quran is the word of God
yes do you think our purpose is to
worship God yes so Life's a test yes
okay do you believe there's life after
death yes what about this one do you
think Jesus and Muhammad are worshiping
the same God yes oh my god do you think
that all the prophets are worshiping the
same God yes
hey chat gbt I have a question do you
think Jesus was God or a prophet what I
want you to do is read the Bible in a
nonbiased perspective I want you to tell
me if it's more likely that Jesus was a
prophet or a God forget the church
forget the Christians I just want you to
read the Bible you must give me an
answer and it must be in less than one
paragraph what does it say reading the
Bible from a non-biased perspective and
focusing solely on its content it's more
likely that Jesus is portrayed as a
prophet the Bible frequently depicts him
as a messenger of God someone who
teaches guides and performs miracles in
God's name which aligns closely with the
role of a prophet while there are
instances where he is referred to in
Divine terms the overall narrative
emphasizes his role as a servant and
messenger of God so guys you saw that
Subhan Allah yeah isn't it amazing that
she's asking some simple questions does
good exist yes it's artificial
intelligence this is you can say
Obviously human beings have given this
information Etc but it's still using
these things that is given to it this
artificial intelligence given to it to
come to basic simple conclusions and
that's exactly the message if you look
at where he asks chat GPT about Jesus
being God no it's not when he asks about
the Bible and says put the different
spin of the the early Church Father Etc
all that to aside just purely going into
the Bible the conclusion is what that
Jesus is not God that God exists that
God is one that there is nothing like
him yes there's a lot of commonalities
when it comes to the Hereafter in the
sense of that we believe in the day of
judgment the Christians believe in the
day of judgment abrahamic fath you know
that the Angels you live in the
scriptures and the prophets Etc we all
believe in that but Subhan Allah it is
profound that she's asking this question
you know there's a verse in the Quran in
Surah Al Imran you know Allah says
indeed in the creation of the heavens
and the Earth and in the outer of the
night and day there are signs for those
who have comprehension and she's used
that to come to this conclusion and she
was confused between Christianity and
Islam at one moment of my life which I
was Islam Christianity Judaism Hinduism
sism but when you even ask an artificial
intelligence it tells you that God is
one and that is what we believe s that
one of the vers in the Quran Allah
says say he is one self-sufficient that
means independent he does not beget nor
is he begotten and there is nothing like
him this is who we believe Allah is the
true creator who sent prophets Prophet
Muhammad Jesus Moses Abraham Noah Adam
all of these prophets came with one
message that God is one so our sister
Lily or I mean you went to uh one of the
coffee places I don't know they wrote
your name as Lea instead of Lily you can
call yourself you can change your name
to Lea if you want it's totally up to
you but that's not prerequisite to
become a Muslim so that I invite you to
Islam in I'm doing this video my dear
sister chat GPT as you can see is not as
smart as you but he or she whoever is
that is or non-binary have said do what
that God is one Jesus is not God so even
that artificial intelligent knows who
the true creator is we invite you to use
your rational logic which you are far
more Superior and intelligent than a
chat GPT that you find God in Islam
inshallah and we invite you we want to
send you a guided prayer out that we
have from our charity uh I've messaged
you on your DMs insh if you can get back
to me our team members can contact you
send you one out for free uh inshallah
so you can learn how to pray and read
the Quran if you have any questions
myself and the team are here inshallah
may Allah subhana guide you and bless
you my dear sister and we enjoy your
videos and brother and sisters if you're
watching this show some uh you know nice
words to her inshallah and yeah that's
all we had to say you can order the mat
if you can get in contact with me or our
salap plus.com website is down but I've
messaged you on the DMS if you get in
contact we can get one of our sisters
team sister feda or sister fuka is an
Italian revert who can get in contact
with you and you can maybe take a sh
with us or with anyone for that matter
till next time